uh it's a string now with Donald Trump
sexual assault accusers of 10 15 17 I
don't even know how many but this
weekend gave us maybe the most
outrageous accusation yet which
effectively amounts to Donald Trump
soliciting prostitution allegedly
offering a pornstar money for sex I'm
talking about porn actress Jessica Drake
who claims that Donald Trump attempted
to come on to her during a 2006 golf
tournament in Lake Tahoe California
Trump has of course denied the
allegations he said he'd never met
Jessica Drake unfortunately we're
showing you a picture of Donald Trump
with Jessica Drake Trump was married to
his third wife Melania when he and Drake
who is now 42 years old met before
Donald Trump teed off at this golf
tournament and Trump as the story goes
allegedly started flirting with Drake
immediately asked her for her phone
number invited her to his penthouse
hotel suite and Drake says she was a
little bit skittish so she brought two
female friends with her and that Trump
aggressively greeted them in his pajamas
grabbed each of them and forcibly kissed
all of them on the lips without asking
for permission exact story that
countless other women have told the
three women left after Trump inquired
about Drake's
relationship status and her sort of
experiences as an adult film star and
later a staffer of Donald Trump
reportedly called Jessica Drake to
invite her back saying reportedly what
do you want how much she declined and
then a second phone call came with an
actual cash offer Jessica Drake saying I
received another call from Donald or a
male calling on his behalf offering me
$10,000 I declined once again saying I
had to go back to LA for work and then
here's where Trump really tried to
sweeten the deal Pat saying if you've
got to get back to LA for work come over
I'll give you the 10k for sex and then
my private plane will fly you back quite
the ladies man this Donald Trump huh
yeah this really adds a whole nother
layer to to the sexual
allegations yeah because if you remember
what took Eliot Spitzer down it wasn't
so much infidelity as it was that he was
hiring prostitutes right and I wouldn't
be surprised if more women of the night
come forward against Trump here Trump
does everything big-league right Jessica
Drake not just a porn star but an
award-winning porn star and I wonder I'm
just throwing it out there how long will
it be until someone comes forward saying
Trump paid to have me get an abortion
and if it happened you know what Trump
would say hey that's because I'm smart
it was legal I take advantage of what's
legal Hillary was a senator why didn't
she make abortion illegal Trump will
make paying for sex great again and
clearly he attempted that according to
Jessica Drake it didn't happen two weeks
and a day before the election more than
a dozen sexual assault accusations
against Donald Trump and his supporters
don't seem to care as they don't seem to
care if he lies in every single debate
many many times more than Hillary
Clinton six seven eight nine ten times
as much as Hillary Clinton and his Trump
famously said he could shoot people on
Fifth Avenue many of his supporters
wouldn't care I think Trump was actually
right about that